let's take a little jaunt around middle
earth and let's
figure out what went wrong with the
hobbit
i enjoyed the hobbit an unexpected
journey
but there's nobody
who liked it as much as the lord of the
rings i mean it's it's all there
isn't it it's got a great cast great
music
we're back in new zealand these
fantastic locations amazing sets
uh incredible costumes same people
behind the scenes
what went wrong peter
jackson forgot how to release
a theatrical film let's look back
at the lord of the rings for a minute
most really hardcore fans only own
the extended edition but there's a
reason they weren't the virgins that
were released in theaters
now those films the lord of the rings
films in their theatrical versions
they were still long movies but they
kept
moving forward they kept on point now
the extended editions
are a bit more loose the most of the
stuff that got added in
is not moving the overall plot forward
it's interesting stuff though i mean it
builds the world more it builds the
characters it it makes everything feel
bigger it lets things breathe a little
more and that's good
for home viewing when you're in a movie
theater you can't
lay back and just kick back and just
sort of let it wash over you you're
there for an experience you're in a
strange place that you've paid to get
into with lousy food and
floors that are sticky the thing needs
to keep moving forward
and peter jackson seems to have
forgotten that because i
i really do believe he put the extended
edition
of an unexpected journey out in theaters
and if
when this thing rolls out of dvd there
is an extended edition i can't imagine
what the hell he's going to put back
in what should have happened with this
film is that all the stuff
that they pulled out of the appendices
and or
out of their butts i'm talking about
galadriel
i'm talking about the necromancer i'm
talking about a
saruman all this additional stuff
tossed in there to tie it more tightly
with the lord of the rings
should not have been in the theatrical
cut that should have been saved
for an extended edition the theatrical
cut
should have just been what was on the
page
of the hobbit we'd lose ratty ass the
brown who i
i actually thought was one of the
highlights but he shouldn't be there
he's got no reason to be there
because all this stuff that was stuck
back in there
it does tie it in better with the lord
of the rings
yes but it has nothing to do with
the hobbit all of it is distracting from
bilbo
and he is supposed to be the focus this
is supposed to be his
adventures this is not supposed to be
oh there's a dark evil building in the
forest oh and by the way some hobbit
found a ring
anyways i'm not saying it's
uninteresting i'm just saying it does
not belong in the theaters
save it for home video peter
god's sake man pull it together
and please just give us something a
little more focused when we get to
desolation of smog because i
i really want this to be good i really
do
and on that pleading pathetic note
this council is adjourned